my name is got latina I'm working for
european space agency operations and
danced at and subjective my talk was
visualizing of cavity potentials and
perturbed Kepler orbits earth Garrity
potential models and perturbed Kepler
orbits sounds a bit exotic exotic here
this turned out to be during a was a
result of a teaching project at ESSEC so
the presentation starts out with a
number of classic subject namely like
traditional with Newton's law of
universal gravitation then gravitational
potential poisons and Laplace equations
and then the gravity potential or field
model of the earth then we turn to the
traditional Kepler orbits which are
known since 15th century and we look in
detail how to solve the Laplace equation
in spherical coordinates look at
perturbations of potentials in spherical
coordinates in on the unit sphere and
then in the whole 3d space and how these
perturbations of the potentials perturb
the Kepler orbits and finally within the
presentation I want to go to the result
of some some recent space missions first
how to exactly precisely measure the
gravity field of the earth and then
present some results from Basin space
missions namely champ grace and ease our
Gorch a mission notations there's there
are some formulas needed and all
quantities they designate vectors or
vector fields in three-dimensional space
and the vertical bars denote the
Euclidean too long regular fonts are
scalars and in terms of units
we use use SI units throughout because
otherwise we end up in a in a mess okay
first start with a recap on Newton's law
of universal gravitation that is there
is also a built-in mathematical formula
that for that so it says it's
proportional to the product of the two
Mize mass is divided by the square of
the distance and the unknown constant is
G yea which was not known at Newton's
time say if you do if you want to do
some calculations here you have to
introduce the coordinate systems and you
have to ride it down in vector equations
then it looks like in this frame formula
and on the bottom I made a template a
nice animation yeah of Newton's law the
main problem we have with gravitation is
that it's incredible feeble yeah so if
you have two masses at work of one
kilogram one meter apart the force is
about seven to the minus eleven Newtons
and therefore i scaled scaled up the
forces here here in this in this
animation so by several powers of ten in
for example you can hear just let the
masses very yeah or you can you can draw
example change the position of the mass
here and then look look what happens so
okay this is classics and if you the
next step is instead of the force here
we usually look at the gravitation field
and the gravitation field vector is
obtained from the force vector by
dividing with the test Marcia which is
in this case m2 and then you get this
formula and in celestial mechanics here
usually the masses are denoted by
capital m and small m for a capital m
for center mass and small import a
satellite mass
and we just use all our for the distance
vector a historic excursion on the
gravitational constant this has been
measured the first time or the earth
mass has been measured the first time by
the physicist Henry Cavendish in 1798
and he designed a whole building
basically to house a torsion balance
which had test masses of about I think
500 kilos yeah and so basically this is
a nice a nice towing of the building
here which he erected and said he wanted
to measure the Earth Mars first but you
can you can derive the cavity constant
from his measurements and you get you
get this value 6.7 10 to the 10 to the
minus 11 meters cubed divided by
kilogram by second squared and the most
recent 2010 coder codata value is not a
lot more accurate here so it contains
just just to basically two more digits
yeah and this is the worst known
physical constant here in the universe
and the problem is for Space Flight we
need a much more accurate knowledge but
we can't get more accurate knowledge of
the cavity constant but of the product g
times m so so now short recap on
mathematics Gauss law for cavity just
reads the divergence of the gravity
field is minus 4 pi times the
gravitational constant times the mass
density then since the gravity is a
conservative conservative force you can
add it as a gradient of a scalar Porter
potential which is usually called Phi so
you can write GS minus the gradient of
Phi the minus sign is use the convention
from physics
and then you can combine these two
equations into a simple in their single
equations namely divergence of the
gradient of Phi which is the laplacian
is 4 pi times G times whole and if your
mass density in every region where this
mass density 0 you get the simple
laplace equation divergence of gradient
of phi is co and you have met matemática
built-in capability for that applies and
yeah so it's just the sum sum of these
derivatives okay so now we can visualize
the gravity potential of the earth as a
point mass so we use the built in
Mathematica date data values from the
planet data namely the earth-mars er
witches sorry with which is about 6
times 10 to 24 kilograms and we use the
earth average they use in this we're in
this node i use the average radio is not
the equatorial radius here which is
about 6,400 kilometers converted to
meters then we can build up the
potential function of a mass point end
of the earth a mass point potential and
here you see then a graphic sia of the
ideal component of the earth exterior
gravity potential this is just a radial
component so at so at the earth service
yeah you get a potential of about minus
six to the seven power 7 meters per
meter squared per seconds and if you saw
it as a they will figure of revolution
here you get this nice presentation so
this is the potential the cavity filled
it's just the radiant or the negative
gradient of the potential field they are
two or three mathematical functions
which are supposed to calculate the
gravity the gradient of this potential
function and if you evaluate it at the
Earth's surface yeah you just get the
usual figures of about minus 9.8 meters
per second square acceleration and here
is again the radial component of the
acceleration yeah so the minus sign
means it's it points inward towards your
service and here vector plot of the of
the earth gravity field so this are all
things which some of you may have say
learned a long time either either at
school or in a elementary physics course
so now let's look at Space Flight we
need two more functions or quantities
namely to calculate the earth escape
velocity the state velocity is that
velocity imparted on a mass point which
is just sufficient that the kinetic
energy is basically the same as negative
potential energy so it's basically solve
solve this equation and gives out a
numerical result and the circular
velocity velocity is calculated from the
equilibrium condition between the inward
gravity acceleration and the outward
centrifugal acceleration which as you
may know is centrifugal acceleration is
V squared divided by r and solve solve
for V then you get these two functions
and here have plotted plotted them you
see at the Earth's surface the other the
escape velocity is about 11,000 meters
per second and the circular velocity is
shortly below 8,000 meters per second so
and now we can show a few examples of
Kepler orbits with different initial
conditions if you start okay
here is our starting point so I started
here at on the Earth's surface job with
an outward pointing velocity vector
which is sub-orbital below below the
circular velocity and then you get a
ballistic orbit and that means you just
you don't get into orbit but you fall
back to the or earth at some point and
these orbits were used here during the
Cold War for so-called ICBMs in the
continental but ballistic missile
missiles here which were supposed to to
fly from the u.s. to the Soviet Union
and vice versa so if you take the
initial velocity exactly tangential yeah
and equal to the circle of velocity here
you get exactly a nice nice circle
circular orbit and if you if you choose
an initial velocity which is higher than
the circular velocity which I have done
in this case yeah then then you get an
elliptic elliptic orbit and finally if
you change or if you have an initial
velocity vector which is exceeding the
velocity at at the corresponding point
in your field then you get a hyperbolic
trajectory so basically start here and
fly on a nice Cape of here around around
the earth so calculations are done just
with n dissolve with within a very short
time ok now bit of hardcore mathematics
namely Laplace equation in spherical
coordinates what we want to do we we
first introduce of course the spherical
coordinates with the mathematical
convention r theta and fee yeah and what
we want to do is to define the potential
over a domain both interior and exterior
to a spherical surface officer of a
given radius you have for spaceflight
applications we of course are interested
in the exterior potential and it shall
satisfy that applies equation and some
the boundary conditions on the surface
and in order to do that here you have to
the classic approach is the separation
of variables you start you separate your
[ __ ] your potential functions into
radial part and an angular part Y of
theta and V plug that into the laplacian
expand it and then do some algebraic
manipulation then you end up with this
nice formula and you see there are two
terms which only depend on our and that
there are three terms which depend only
on theta and Phi and therefore this the
first group of terms is equal to an
arbitrary constant and the end since
they sum up 20 the second group of terms
is the negative of that arbitrary
constant yeah so we we get these two
equations you can try to do it in
Mathematica but you will spend about a
year to do that the solution of this
part here is easily found here it's just
a linear combination of two power
functions r to the power 1 and r to the
power minus 1 minus n they you can
verify here and i've done this year with
matematica that they these linear
combinations of the radial part and that
means these power functions are the
eigen Fang I in function of this of this
differential operator here in
denominator ok this is the radial part
and now comes the angular part if we
restrict the laplacian to the surface of
the sphere by setting r equal to 1 we
get we get this simplified version of
the laplacian and it can be shown that
the spherical harmonics y m
NM of theta and if I are the
eigenfunctions of this operator with
with these eigenvalues and here is just
a short demonstration for the first 10
values yeah so this is the eigen value
calculation and this is just the table
of minus n times n plus 1 they are
identical this is of course not a
mathematical proof but just a
demonstration so and the spherical
harmonics they are awfully complicated
formula so they consist of a factor
depending on N and M then often a
polynomial of cosine theta and
multiplied with a complex exponential e
to the power i M Phi and p MN other
associated like LaShonda functions and
the built in mathematical function they
are complex they are not suitable for
for our applications here so we need to
decompose it into a real and imaginary
part so this was a hardcore and now
comes the graphical part here is I
introduced here a color function very
simple one yeah positive values are
colored red and negative values are
colored blue otherwise white and then I
just plot the first few spherical
harmonics yeah the first one is just
simple sphere the second one also looks
like a sphere but it looks very peculiar
and the for all the two they look like
this year so that and blue parts so this
comes here from the space can artifact
namely it these are two overlaid spheres
one is blue and one is great and
therefore looks like this so and here
the imaginary part also here and
overlaid sphere and the corresponding
terms of order to you know these are
also known known or similar functions
are known from
two mechanics now there is a very very
nice classification of these spherical
harmonics they are subdivided in the
tonal tehsil and sectoral spherical
harmonics the tonal ones are those for
where the index m is zero and if the
index m is between 0 and n these are
called the so called Tessa well
spherical harmonics this comes from the
Latin word for tile cassava and finally
if M equals M then we have the sectoral
spherical harmonics and here I've start
here with the tonal harmonics function
of a device yeah and now I can just let
run the simulation for the index over
various over various index entities and
then you see on the coloring why the
term tesoro and tonal here has been has
been introduced and you see of course
also the limitations of the of the
resolution of the of the discretization
so ok these are just the designs and now
let's look what happens if we put up on
the unit sphere if we perturb the
identity function by such fear achill a
spherical function and one small step is
we just need to remove the normalization
of the mathematical spherical functions
so that they are comparable with the one
yeah and then then we get in coarse
resolution you know we get we get these
these functions on the unit sphere
so they look look a bit odd but I had to
to limit basically two to speed a
representation otherwise it may lock up
my my computer okay and if you if we go
here increase say to the maximum just
march then you see what what's it's all
about and I need to go to speak to the
presentation this is what yeah you get a
very strange figures here which are in
this all in this scope okay
if you are patient you can use the high
resolution and you see it much better
but as I said it may look up my computer
therefore I prefer to have my own so now
these are the where the spherical
harmonics they can be extended to the
whole space by the spatial part and this
is done by expressing the computer a
complete real solution of the Laplace
equation then as a linear combination
after spherical harmonics here platt end
here multiplied with with the radial
solution our head to the power minus 1
minus n where our head is just the
dimensionless they issue between our
radius and the function of earned and
the radius of the sphere then you can do
various algebraic manipulations with
that and in the you factor out we want
to insert a factor out the potential of
a point mass here in this case yes minus
g times m f divided by r put that in
front and then we end up with this
representation of our spherical
harmonics which i have used them for the
subsequent calculations and here now
I've show you the equipotential surfaces
of this disturbed potentials yeah with
these spherical solid solid spherical
harmonics and this is so just starting
with order N equals 2 + + index N equals
1 and if I let them hear the the index
you get also the sine sine part and what
you see here is that inner the inner
equipotential surfaces they they are
have large deviations from spherical
shell squares the father you go go out
then they more and more approach
spherical equipotential surfaces that
means the potential approaches the 11 /
are ya okay so and now the last part
let's look what these solids spherical
harmonics we are due to a Kepler orbit
yeah so I started again here here with
with an order N equals 2 yeah so that
means basically it corresponds to a
flattened birth yeah and and calculate
calculate Kepler orbit with a certain
with a certain initial conditions and
then you can see her now strange things
happening this is here are the initial
conditions so we started at five hundred
kilometers altitude and the Kepler orbit
of course is is close to a circular
orbit it's planar here but if you
introduce such a perturbations here from
flattening of the earth what happens is
that to get very there is compared the
patients that orbit is no longer planar
yeah it's not closed here it's bent also
outside of the plane this is of course
all highly exaggerated here in nature
such strong perturbations don't occur
but you can't see them we are if you if
you use the coefficients from actual
earth you won't see anything yeah okay
so I just hesitated here to change
change setting here because it may may
lock up my computer it takes about 20
seconds theater opening here ok now
let's let's look how we can precisely
measure the cavity filled of the earth
first first of all we need to understand
the definition of the geo idea it's the
shape of the surface of the oceans would
take under the influence of just Earth's
cavitation and rotation alone and the
GOI t means that if you put a plumb line
yeah above it here it's just
perpendicular to the g-ride and the
water level is parallel to the G right
and then there is also important concept
the reference ellipsoid it's just
mathematical defined surface that
approaches the G white so what one can
do in practice and has done over the
last 200 more than 200 years you can
measure the surface gravity with
so-called spring gravimeters this figure
just chose you shows you the principle
of that and they have in the meantime
now a really astonishing accuracy 10 to
the minus 8 meters per second squared
and in space flight h you can use for
example satellite hiking and the most
precise one is with satellite laser
ranging and the most prominent species
of that is the laser geodynamic
satellite launched in 1976 yeah which is
still in orbit it's a metal bowl of 400
kilos with laser they'd have reflectors
and you can use a satellite altimetry
and the last picture shows shows the
principles of satellite altimetry now
let's
come to the space missions and results
here over the past one and a half
decades the first one in this sector in
this sector was the champ missions
mission which is stands for challenging
mini satellite payload was a German mini
satellite project which was developed by
gear for Zhang centum in in potsdam and
10 years mission duration and did hide
highly precise gravity and magnetic
field measurements here you see this is
a picture of the satellite and it shows
here the logo shows all the organization
which were involved in that and here you
see one of the scientific results of the
Chum isms this is the GOI t is
determined by by Cheng and let's see if
that if that works so this is of course
again highly exaggerated here the Geo
I'd figure opt owpain obtained from that
okay next a mission in that sequence was
the place space space mission this was
also a small space mission of two tandem
satellites cooperation project between
NASA and the German dlr here are some
more facts on a mission the important
thing is it consisted of two of a tandem
of satellites you have which flew on the
same polar orbit and the important new
feature what they use they used a knife
microwave link which exactly measured
the distance between the solar
satellites as they passed over the
gravity anomalies and this gives
enormous precision measurements on the
gravity perturbations and here are some
results from the trace space mission
also the gravity anomalies and here
gravity anomalies over there
did you strum the from this mission okay
and the last thing in that sequence is
either the gorgeous space mission
gorgeous stands for gravity field and
steady-state ocean circulation Explorer
it was launched in 2009 mission has
already ended here because it was at a
very low orbit at 260 kilometers and
there it had all this experience
atmospheric drag and therefore it needed
an iron engine basically to constantly
push it here and as soon as the rule is
exhausted the thing really ended and
burned up in the atmosphere and here you
see the 22 of the gravity field models
from the from the Commission one at the
beginning and one at the end yeah and
that concludes the presentation and